it's considering offering financial
incentives to hire new bus drivers and
also keep the ones that they currently
have this proposal will be discussed at
tomorrow's school board meeting kate
houston live in studio to break down how
much money is being offered and how it
could fill all those vacancies kate yes
denise over the past few months we've
heard that school buses are chronically
late or don't show at all and this has
forced the district to come up with some
creative solutions such as partnering
with rtc and now offering nearly two
thousand dollars to employees i've tried
everything humanly possible i you know
called the school i called the
transportation i even called rtc to try
and get her a pass molly kiley is on the
phone every morning at 7am to check if
her granddaughter will get a bus ride to
school if there's not a bus available
then she
just sits there she's been at the stop
for two
hours in the morning waiting for a bus
sometimes kiley says there isn't a
designated driver on their bus route
that vacancy is one of 240 in the
district she's missed school several
times because there is no bus or she's
late to school because the bus never
doesn't get there on time in an effort
to fill open positions the school
district and the education support
employees association created an
incentive proposal both new hires and
current employees are eligible for three
installments of 500 dollars contingent
upon training and high attendance an
employee referral can also lead to 500
dollars while kylie does think this is a
good idea she's worried it isn't quick
enough i wish they'd done it earlier in
the year but better late than never i
guess the district and e-s-e-a say there
will be no financial impact since the
funds are from current vacancies
if approved those incentives would be
available until june 30 of next year the
school board will discuss and
potentially approve that proposal at
tomorrow night's meeting at 5 p.m back
to you